Lisa Marie Presley passed away today
your thoughts you know what I found out
on my way over to the theater and I just
thought to myself life is so short and
so precious because I was just watching
her on the Globes I just think we have
to squeeze the people we love a little
harder
because weird things are happening
and I are headed to LAX and we need you
to pick us up on Monday keep your
location on the entire time I'm away hi
this is Grace Allen please leave a
message
Mom where are you guys my mom never came
home from her trip I don't know where
she is this movie is fantastic we were
on the set I didn't think it I didn't
think it was going to be like this I
know isn't it like so thrilling and like
you just like you're holding like onto
the edge of your seat the whole time are
you tech savvy like June is in this
movie no her typing is incredible
incredible thank you I think fines and
the things she can do it I have learned
so much from her I'm like a full-on pi
now actually oh yeah
um also did you see storm making her
debut tonight with shador her man no
who plays quarterback at Colorado they
made their debut tonight
I'm gonna have to go and have a little
interview with him you need to talk to
him talk to him he's living that life
right now
dear God no more sports for me right no
yeah you're done you're done you're done
you did like
watching now what they did when you were
shooting on set and it was just basic
stuff like yeah it's amazing in the
background how you do stuff in the
background walking by walking through
the car yeah
how is it shooting that well I just
remember there was one night we were
losing the light I had I was driving the
car I had the phone here storm was in
the back seat saying her lines to me and
I was trying to drive and do all these
things at one time and talking into you
know a blank screen right right I'm used
to like I'm I like give and take give
and take but but that's actually what I
really appreciate about the film because
it was challenging and I think we all
get to a certain point in our careers
where we want to be challenged and it
was great in that way okay now can we
talk about best man and the way people
are losing their mind over best man and
they want more we need more what is it
going there's more why isn't there more
just don't think so
I I don't know I mean listen I would do
more I think if if everyone came back
together and wanted to do more I think
we I don't know we might Maybe
say it into the Kim you will do more I'm
not going to say they would have to back
the truck up but but
I did all right I think they did all
right I did great we we thank you
peacock for all your love and support
and for just being behind this project
in the way that you have but if we do
another one I will need that truck to be
like beep
you people how much fun was it making
that movie because it is a movie that it
feels like the updated Guess Who's
Coming to Dinner you know it was so much
fun I love Lauren London I love Kenya I
mean it was like making a movie with my
friends right
what are you wearing tonight because you
look great come on oh please did I say
that right yes you did I said it right
okay go ahead Mama I'm not like a name
brand girl I just wear what I like
she's Nia Long she knows she hits me
along stop
oh
[Music]